better late than never the massive surge
in retail theft in blue cities finally
caught the attention of the liberal
media it only took shocking scenes of
grocery stores chaining up the ice cream
like it was some National Treasure CNN
visiting one Walgreens in San Francisco
and they were shocked I tell you
so typical that in the 30 minutes we
were at this Walgreens
we watched three people including this
man steal did that guy pay
did that guy pay
he didn't pay this was bizarre something
I'd never seen before this is just more
icing on the cake
telling us that rampant crime is is has
become a regular part of life it's
become kind of like a police state in
San Francisco I don't know how to
describe it really yeah and while the
liberal media gets a crash course on
crime we're learning that Mexican drug
cartels are fueling America's
shoplifting search they're selling the
soul and stuff online and then
laundering the profits through guess
where Chinese Brokers so Dana CNN
finally discovered crime is a crisis in
San Francisco this is after they made
fun of us for pointing it out last year
and with two years which was um also
that was around the same time they said
that there was no crime in New York City
because two of their anchors had been
out to dinner Don Lemon and they had
been approached and they were like oh
thank you so much for doing we'd love to
show and everything everything's fine in
New York uh have you they they probably
took a car service guaranteed because it
is bad out there and I'd like to have a
word with the mayor the litter is
unbelievable you have tourists here
every day and I'm like I feel so bad I
mean why can't you just clean this up
every day like they do at Berman Street
that's what you do and you have a lot of
tourists it's gross and it's horrible on
this point I think that finding out that
there are Mexican cartels behind some of
this makes me think that maybe there's
hope that we could figure out a way to
do something about it so the State
Attorneys General are banding together
and they're like let's go after it but
also they need the help of the retailers
the retailers don't want to be looted
like this either but the problem to me
is that all this stuff gets taken and
then it's resold online
like on Amazon for example so can Amazon
help us out because somehow can they
figure out a way to track it we've got
AI we've got all these other tools there
must be a way to try to prevent all of
this from happening you could put up a
task force maybe with the FBI bring in
the DEA make it transnational Greg since
the cartels are involved I think that's
a good a good suggestion I was just
thinking about the fact that if they
were stealing ice cream two years ago
maybe stelter would have said something
Greg or perhaps they were stealing giant
Q-tips
Chris Cuomo would have been whoa hold on
a second that's supposed to go up my
nose in a comedy segment uh it's weird
to see these cartels diversify they're
almost like Amazon now they're doing
drugs smuggling and theft pretty soon
they're gonna have their own podcast you
know um but I think but there's no other
thing that we said a long time ago and I
bet we don't bombing the cart remember
we said we're talking about bombing the
cartels and people go no no no that's an
act of War that's in another country so
yeah but we do that to terrorists as
well and this is kind of a terrorist
activity and and the thing is now you
see at least on the Republican side a
lot of candidates are talking about
doing it and I think it's a good idea I
think we need to elect a president who
values a border that's the important
thing Bob these and if there's like one
cartel we can cooperate with let them
kill the rest encourage them to kill the
rest judge remember when the Chinese
were ripping off our DVDs and we sent
the entire Federal Government after them
and and we actually were pretty
effective this is pretty similar in
terms of now it's shoplifting yeah yeah
and I remember Prosecuting a case for
the Motion Picture Association because
what they were doing was that people
were going in and they were just making
copies of movies oh yeah I watched a few
movies like that where the guy just
holds the camcorder in the theater yes I
mean my friend watched this yes all
right so listen uh this is part of uh
you know a global global organized
criminal activity uh the problem is that
this this organization is not just doing
retail theft they're also doing human
trafficking they're doing fentanyl
they're doing all kinds of crime and so
they're expanding their criminal Network
and now they're going to be so powerful
I don't know if we're ever going to be
able to defeat them because we've got a
president right now who you know with
the border and they're in charge at the
border uh there is nothing going on
that's preventing the fentanyl from
coming in we hear about an arrest now
and then it's usually the locals who are
making the rest and not the federal
government but the the issue is whether
or not these criminals you know are
being prosecuted now that guy walked out
right and then the person in the store
says it's a police state for everyone so
for the victims it's a police state but
the criminal it's not a police statement
that's very that's the actual problem
it's low risk and it's high reward low
risk because the employee is not going
to punch you out you're not going to get
arrested you're going to make a fortune
and so you're going to start this
business and you're going to launder
your money through China and unless we
get serious about this whether it's
bombing or whatever the the the you have
to come up with something these
organizations are dangerous they are
absolutely dangerous and for everybody
at home your insurance is going to go up
because of it the cost of retail and
consumer products are going to go up
you're paying for this yep what is the
Joe Biden anti-cartel strategy Jessica
I don't know exactly what it is either
okay well we're tied for once
um no I I assume there's I don't know
from I don't have the policy off the top
of my head I know it's something that he
has spoken about it's obviously
something that he's concerned about I
know that he's spoken to the Mexican
president about it
um and I know that things are going
better at the border whether it's using
the cpb one app which seems to be
working with 1250 people a day
registering with that so we know who's
actually coming into the country versus
streaming across or the fact that border
crossings are down that 70 percent writ
large but I to Dana's point I did think
that it was at least some semblance of
good news that if this is organized
there's some prayer of stopping it and
that it just is in every single average
American is happy to be walking into
stores and ripping us off and walking
around town like zombies strung out on
whatever that this is actually a
coordinated attack that hopefully we can
have a good solution to and end up
solving okay when when Joe has that
solution you let us in Jesse you know
one of the things that the Biden
Administration has done and talked about
in the state of the unions but they want
to go after junk fees remember like the
junkies and they're really hot on it and
I heard of this on NPR the other day
they really focus on but the judge is
exactly right this is costing everybody
is paying this criminal fee because of
the prices that are going up at the
store message to Joe Biden what stay off
my junk
okay Greg
shouldn't be hard
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else